I'm Kian Caton-Fourouche and I am the co-creator and
co-lecturer with Andrew for this class, CS230.
And I will teach about half of the in-person lectures this quarter.
Outside of Stanford, I work in industry.
I lead a company called Workera, which uses AI to measure skills.
And with the history of CS230 students that have started AI startups and
companies, what I try to do usually is to bring a lot of examples from industry.
So what you should expect from these in-class lectures is not as much
of the academic side of things which we learn anyway in the online videos,
but also the industry specific inputs.
And some of the topics that we cover this year together
include decision making in AI projects, which we're going to see today.
I want you to come out of today's lecture feeling like you had some fun,
it was interactive, and also you have a better way to make decisions in AI projects
because you've seen how deep learning researchers, engineers and scientists
make their decisions solving problems in industry.
Other topics later in the quarter for the in-classroom time include
things like adversarial attacks and defenses.
We might have some time to cover it today.
Deep reinforcement learning, which is really hot in the market right now,
and I think it's very important to know about it.
And then all the stuff that is very practical, like retrieval,
augmented generation, AI agents, multi-agent system.
As we go deeper into the class and you get the baggage of neural networks,
we'll be able to cover even more fun topics.
So today's lecture is going to be structured in three parts,
maybe four depending on whether we have time.
We'll start with a little recap of the week,
what you've learned online about neurons and layers and deep neural networks.
Then we get into a set of supervised learning projects,
including a day and night simple, you know, vanilla classification,
the trigger word detection, which is actually a project you're going to build
at the end of the class yourself, and then face verification,
which we'll see also variation of how face verification algorithms work.
In the third section, we focus on self-supervised learning
and weekly supervised learning.
Don't worry if you don't know these terms.
We're going to learn them together and we'll talk a lot about embeddings
because embeddings are the connective tissue of many AI systems online today
and it's important to know about them.
And finally, if we have time, we'll also talk about adversarial attacks
and defenses with more and more AI systems in the wild.
Knowing how to defend them is very important and knowing how to attack them
can also teach you how to defend them.
So we'll cover that as well.
Sounds good.
Please interrupt me as we go through the lecture.
We want this to be very conversational as much as possible.
So recap of the week is the core way that AI learns from data
in a traditional supervised learning setup.
You can think of it as an input such as this little image
of the confused cat and an output, in this case, a number between 0 and 1
that represents the chance that there might be a cat on the picture 1
or there is no cat on the picture 0.
What the model is, and oftentimes you'll see me refer to the model
as two things, there's an architecture,
which is essentially the blueprint of the model, the skeleton, and parameters.
It might be a few parameters, it might be billions of parameters
like the models that OpenAI, DeepMind, and others work on.
Outside of that, and so when you think about AI models being deployed in the wild,
like when you think about what's happening with ChatGPT,
you can really come down to there's two files somewhere on the cloud,
one that describes the architecture of the model,
one that describes the parameters that are part of this architecture,
and you keep calling those two files
and you get your inference or your outputs.
That's really what's happening behind the scene,
much more complicated than that obviously,
but those are the two critical components of a neural network,
architecture and its parameters that are trained.
How does the model learn is through a gradient descent optimization,
meaning I send the picture of the cat through the model
and the model at the beginning is not trained, so it's probably wrong.
It tells me, I think there's no cat, I think it's zero,
and then I use something called the loss function to compare the ground truth.
There is a cat on the picture with the prediction from the model
at this point in time.
Those two numbers are far from each other.
That should be a penalty, which the loss function describes,
and then in order to give feedback to the parameters,
we use this gradient descent updates.
We do that many, many times.
What it means is that we take our parameters and we tell them,
hey, you should go a little bit more to the right
or a little bit more to the left until that number
that is the prediction for the cat is closer to the ground truth.
We do that with batches of data,
millions of images of cats and images of anything else,
and we give that feedback repetitively to the model
until the parameters are calibrated
and the model is in fact finding the cat on this picture.
Nothing new here, you've seen it in the videos.
Any question on that learning setup?
No?
Okay, easy so far.
There's many things that can change in this setup
and you'll see in the class.
First thing is the input.
The input does not have to be an image.
It can be text, like when you chat, you know, we chat GPT.
It can be audio, it can be video, it can be structured data,
it can be spreadsheets and numbers.
Those we see a variety of examples in the class
and how it influences the architecture.
The output again doesn't have to be zero and one.
This is an example of a classification.
You could turn this problem into a regression.
For example, if I was asking you
what's the age of the cat,
estimate the age of the cat,
that would be a regression task,
not a classification task anymore.
Later in the class, we'll also see generative task.
In fact, lecture four is gonna focus on diffusion models,
generative adversarial networks,
where the output actually is much bigger
than the input typically, you know.
So you can have a low resolution of a cat as input
and the output is a high resolution of the same cat.
The output is bigger than the inputs,
which can be counter-intuitive to people.
Other things that can change include the architecture.
You've learned about the vanilla multilayer perceptron
or the fully connected neural network.
That's what we're learning right now online together.
By the end of the class,
you'll have many architectures that you'll be familiar with
from RNNs and convolutional neural networks,
transformer models.
All of these, at the end of the day,
use the basis neural network
that you're learning right now.
They're just stacked on top of each other differently.
The loss function is actually a big focus of today's class
and of the class in general.
The loss function, which is what gives the feedback
to the model, you were right or you were wrong
and what to do about it is an art.
Designing good loss functions,
great deep learning researchers are very creative
when it comes to designing loss functions.
And in fact, when we built the algorithm called YOLO,
it is called YOLO for you only look once,
not you only live once,
but YOLO has a very, you know,
difficult to understand at first loss function
and there's a reason why the loss function
was designed like that.
So by the end of this class,
you'll also have a better intuition
on how do we design great loss functions.
Other things I'm not gonna cover right now,
the activation functions in your neural network,
the optimizer that you use for your gradient descent loop
and then the hyperparameters that might come in
when you train your algorithms.
Okay, nothing new here.
This is the basic setup.
You've also learned this week about neurons.
The easiest way to think about a neuron
is the classic logistic regression algorithm
where I'm taking the image of the cat.
So an image in computer science,
the way the machine reads it is three channels,
RGB for the three colors, red, green, blue.
And we take all these numbers,
we put them in a vector,
the vector is then fed into a neuron
and the neuron has two components,
the linear part, W transpose X plus B,
W being the weight and B being the bias
and then an activation function.
In this case, the sigmoid function,
which is very handy because it takes any number
and it puts it between zero and one
so that the output can look like a probability.
Classic setup.
And here the probability is 0.73,
which is above 0.5,
which tells me the model thinks
there's a cat on the picture
because one is a cat, zero is no cat.
So question for you to get started.
How would you modify this binary classification
that detects cats in an algorithm
that would be able to detect multiple animals
such as a cat, a dog and a giraffe?
What do you need to change about this neural network?
Yeah.
Okay, so you would change the output layer
to match to the number of animals you wanna detect.
Yeah, correct.
Anyone wants to add anything else?
Yeah.
The data that goes in there,
how would you change the data?
Okay, very good.
Yeah, you need data from dogs and giraffes
and also maybe nature in general.
What else do we need not to forget?
Yeah.
Yeah, okay.
Add one neuron per animal,
those neurons will be independent from each other
and each neuron would focus on one animal.
Yeah, good point.
It's actually what we're gonna do.
So yes, I think your suggestions were the right one.
We could multiply this output layer
to have three neurons instead of one.
All of them, because it's a fully connected neural net,
see the entire pixels flattened in the vector
and then each of them will be focused on an animal.
The number one mistake that we see in projects
is that people add more data
but forget to adjust the labels.
So how do the labels need to be adjusted here?
It's not anymore zero and one, right?
What type of labels do we need to train this?
Yeah, yeah, okay.
You know how we call that?
Okay, so yeah, yeah.
Yeah, vectors, yeah.
I think you're saying the same thing.
Yeah, so here you would use a one-hot vector
or a multi-hot.
One-hot means you'll have a vector of size three
and if there is a cat on the picture,
the label is gonna be zero, one, zero
because the second neuron is gonna be responsible
to detect cats.
In fact, that would be called the one-hot vector.
Oftentimes, you'll have multiple animals on the picture
because cats and dogs can appear together.
Cats and giraffes less so
and dogs and giraffes,
I've never seen one in the same picture
but anyway, you'll have a multi-hot vector.
If you have a cat and a dog on the picture,
you'll probably label it as one, one, zero.
And the reason I'm mentioning that,
it may sound silly but in a lot of projects,
people change their data,
they forget to change their labels
and then they wonder why it doesn't work.
Okay, cool.
Now, in the class, we use a specific notation
with superscript and subscript
so when you see me refer to something like A11,
the superscript in square brackets
indicates the layer that you're in.
So you're in the first layer.
The subscript refers to the index of the neuron, okay?
And A is for activation.
So A subscript three, square bracket one,
is the output of the third neuron of the first layer, okay?
Again, if I continue,
second layer would be written like that
and then you'll get your probability.
The deeper the network is, the more capacity it has.
What's the word we use?
Capacity.
What it means is that if you send
a million pictures of cats
and a million pictures of non-cats to a shallow network,
it might not have the capacity
to learn what's in the dataset.
It's just not flexible enough.
The deeper the network, the more capacity it has.
So in fact, a network that is super deep,
imagine a billion-parameter transformer model
with one million pictures of cat and non-cat,
it will just overfit to those pictures,
meaning it's not gonna learn what a cat is,
it's just gonna learn by heart those million pictures
because its capacity is way bigger
than the dataset it's fed.
So it's very important to understand
the amount of data you're gonna feed
and the complexity, diversity of that data
will probably dictate the capacity
of the models you need to use.
Okay, now just to give you a little bit more intuition
on what happens inside those neural networks,
we take this relatively shallow network,
but call it three layers,
and we train it on a dataset of facial images.
Ignore the task.
In face datasets, there's a lot of tasks you could do.
You could do a face verification,
you could do a face recognition,
you could do face clustering, things like that.
We'll talk about that later,
but let's say it's been trained really well
on understanding faces.
If you now unpack this network
and you sort of query each neuron
and look what's going on inside,
what you'll notice is that the first layers
are gonna be better at encoding low-complexity features,
while the deeper networks are gonna be better
at encoding higher-complexity features.
So here's how it goes, nothing too complicated for now.
The neuron in the first layers,
they're looking at pixels,
because you're giving them directly the pixels.
So they're gonna be good
at stitching those pixels together,
the first neuron will be good at detecting a diagonal edge,
the second neuron will be good at vertical edges,
and the third one at horizontal edges,
because they're just looking at pixels
and trying to make sense out of them.
Now you go one layer deeper in the middle of the network.
Those are not seeing pixels,
they're seeing the output of the first layer,
which is already slightly more complex.
So what you can expect the layers
in the middle of the network to give you
or to activate for is higher level features,
like an eye or a nose or an ear,
because it turns out if you have a few edges,
you can start detecting circles.
And so you would see a neuron
that is really good at detecting circles, eyes.
The deeper you go in the network,
the more you get closer to the task itself,
which in this case, facial analysis, let's say,
you would see the last few neurons
detect larger features of the face,
because again, they're seeing higher-complexity information.
Does that make sense?
This concept, we call it encoding.
We'll also talk about embeddings.
It's very important because when you train neural networks,
you wanna make sure first
that they're understanding what they're doing.
And that's one way to see it.
We'll have an entire lecture on interpreting
and visualizing neural networks later this quarter.
And on top of that,
you probably can make use
of some of those encodings and embeddings.
We'll see that later.
But why in the vector space,
the distances between those concepts are important.
You can already imagine that for tasks like search,
searching in a database,
having a neural network able to encode information
in a very meaningful way
can allow you to find concepts that are close
to each other and associate them with each other
and concepts that are far from each other
and dissociate them from each other.
Okay, so this was the warmup for today.
How much time we spent?
Okay, 15 minutes on the warmup.
That's good.
So we learned a few new words,
model, architecture, parameters.
I didn't talk about it,
but feature engineering versus feature learning.
That's the core concept in deep learning
is feature engineering
is what we used to do before deep learning,
which is you might actually build an algorithm
that is good at detecting eyes.
It's just good at scanning eyes.
You manually build it.
And then you build another one
that is good at detecting a mouth.
And then you put them together
to feel and detect faces.
We don't do that anymore.
We do end-to-end learning,
meaning we let the data speak for itself
and train the model.
This is called feature learning.
It's automatic.
And that's how the neural network
actually learns those features
without you needing to tell it
eyes are important to detect faces.
You don't need to do that.
Encoding and embedding.
The real difference is encoding
is any vector representation
and an embedding though, sorry,
it should have been an embedding is
when an encoding has meaning,
meaning the distance between two encodings has meaning.
They might be close or far from each other
and it tells you something.
There is a logic to it.
And then we talked about one-hot and multi-hot vectors.
Okay.
So end of the recap now.
Let's go into supervised learning projects
and we're gonna make decisions together
and walk through it.
The first case study is day and night classification.
So here's my problem for you.
Given an image that I give you,
classify it as whether it's the day
or whether it's the night.
Okay, open-ended problem.
Ignore that foundation models exist.
You don't have access to chat GPT or cloud or whatever.
The point is to get under the hood
and have those discussions
because obviously it's a toy example.
So what do you do?
Like what data do you wanna collect to solve this problem?
Start.
Yes.
So tell me more.
Check how pixels in the same row are.
What does it tell you that if you look at the row
of pixel and the row next to it,
if they're very different, what does it tell you?
Okay, so you say if the delta between pixels
that are closed geographically to each other is high,
then there's probably colors, color changes.
So it's day most likely, is that it?
Okay.
So that's an example of feature engineering.
It's like you're going for it and great.
Like you're going for it
and you're trying to understand what's a pattern
that tells me that a picture is day or night.
What else can you do in the world of neural networks?
The other ideas?
Yeah.
Okay, good, yeah.
So yeah, I agree.
I said 10,000 images,
but how do you even determine how many pictures you need
to get started with this project?
Feed some data.
So you start with like 10 pictures
and then you continue to go.
Yeah, you could do that.
Might take some time.
I think the question is how easy is it
to collect that data?
Like how would you collect that data?
Okay, yeah, we could put our phone out there
and then record the day and the night
and have a stream of pictures
and add it to the data set.
Same location, but different lightings.
Yeah, that's a great point.
So just to repeat for the people online,
you have to define the task first
because the task can be easy.
You can be in a park in a very specific location
and say just detect if it's day or night
or you can have a problem
which is your camera can be anywhere
and that makes it more complicated.
And also the amount of data you'll need
is probably much more for that second problem.
That's what you said, right?
Now, actually that's a great thread.
Tell me about cases where this problem
would be really hard to solve.
Yeah, yeah, indoor, indoor pictures.
Actually, can you, how could you tell
if you took a picture of me with the screen here,
what time it was?
You couldn't?
You actually can, yeah.
There's a clock here.
So that's very interesting
because if that was part of the task,
then our problem would be hard
and 10,000 images is not gonna cut it
to understand time.
And so it's very important to define the task very well.
What else can be hard other than indoor pictures?
Also, also the clock can be AM or PM
but you can probably take additional information
which is how people are dressed
and think that it might be warmer outside than colder.
You could, again, it can be very complicated
at the end of the day.
But a human would say someone is teaching,
students are in class,
it's probably not 12 AM, you know.
So I mean like it gets complicated.
What else can be hard?
Okay, sunny, cloudy, yeah.
Great point.
If you're in the north of Norway right now or Sweden,
even the clock can tell you probably if it's day or night.
Dawn and dusk, yeah, exactly.
Those are great examples.
Actually, this is a good semantic one
because you'd need also to define
exactly what's the definition of day and night.
So long story short,
the problem can seem easy at first
and can be very complicated.
And trust me, if you wanted to do this really well,
even the foundation models today
couldn't do it in certain cases.
Okay, let's say we have 10,000 images
and you talked about the split of images earlier
and I agree with you.
You want a mix of different situations
in order to be able to cover all of them.
And going back to our discussion on model capacity,
if it's just a simple problem,
you probably need just a small capacity model.
If you want to add all these edge cases,
you probably are looking for bigger capacity models
and more data.
What's the inputs to our model?
I think someone said it already.
So let's say a picture of a day or night or whatever.
What's the resolution we're gonna work with?
How do you determine resolution when you build a data set
and why does it matter?
Yes, yeah.
Okay, so you want to choose a resolution
that's gonna be the same across the board.
You're gonna vectorize everything
that's gonna fit in the same size matrix.
Yeah, why is it important to have
the right resolution, let's say.
Okay, so you're saying we want homogeneity
in the data set in terms of resolution.
I would say that could be a thing,
but today you can actually write scripts
that downsize high resolution images
before it gets in the model.
And so it would probably solve.
Upsizing is slightly harder.
You would need another algorithm,
but it's okay to have different resolutions,
but you still wanna know what's the target resolution
that you're looking for.
Exactly.
Low resolution, we lack information,
so we might get things wrong.
For example, the clock might not appear in the picture
if it's too low resolution.
High resolution means more compute needed.
If you have big pictures,
it's gonna be heavier to train your model,
and you're gonna pay more,
and also your cycles of iterations are gonna be longer.
In an AI project, that's why resolution matter a lot.
So my question is what resolution do we go for?
Is there a way to just get to a number really quickly
in the next 10 minutes, let's say,
if we were doing this project?
Yeah, who's?
Oh yeah, exactly.
I think that's a great idea.
You're saying use the human as a proxy?
Yeah, so actually, this is how we did it.
Back in the days, we would print pictures
in different resolutions and run it through our friends
and say, can you tell if it's the day or the night?
And it turns out that below a certain resolution,
we can't anymore.
It's just like, I don't have the information I need.
And where we ended is somewhere around 64 by 64 by three.
And I stress the three because later this quarter,
we'll see that OpenAI and DeepMind,
DeepMind as well in reinforcement learning,
turns out for one of the famous algorithm
we learned together for reinforcement learning,
discovered that you can actually remove colors
and the model is not impacted,
but your training is way simpler.
In this case, I think colors matter
because of the blue sky,
because it does have an inherent information
about whether it's day or night.
And it turns out the task, if you give it to humans,
is much harder without colors than it is with colors.
So those type of insights we could get
over the next 10 minutes, literally,
by using humans as a proxy.
This is a toy example,
but I want you to think about that in your AI project.
You're gonna be at points
where you wanna validate the hypothesis
and the best proxy you'll have is the human.
Okay, what's the output for this model?
Yeah, day or night, zero or one?
Yeah, good question.
So does the size of the image impact the input layer?
The size of the input layer, is that it?
Yeah, it doesn't.
You can make your decisions.
You can have three neurons
and you send the massive picture inside it.
Oftentimes, and that's why I often say
deep learning is an engineering field.
You have to try it or you have to know the hacks.
Typically, the network, if it's a,
in a binary classification,
you're going from a high dimensional input
to a very low dimensional output.
So by nature, you'd imagine your network
is gonna be like this, probably.
Meaning you need more edge detection at the beginning
and then higher feature and higher feature
until at the end it detects the face.
So it's gonna be like that.
We're gonna see examples in week four
where the output is bigger than the inputs
and your network is probably like this.
So you'll build intuition during the class
to know when you want to downsize your input layer
or upsize your input layer.
And by the way, these hacks are valuable.
Why does Meta go out and give crazy offers
to a few researchers?
Because they know that stuff.
They know those hacks, literally.
Okay.
Okay, so again, someone said it.
The output is zero or one.
The last activation is gonna be a sigmoid.
Yes, question?
Yeah, you can do that.
You can probably say in the data set,
I don't care of the sizes
because I'm scraping data from everywhere.
I'm collecting data on my phone.
I'm putting it all in a database.
I write a script that down samples or up samples
everything to the same resolution.
And then I send those lower res images in the network
because what I care about is the training of my network.
I want it to be fast and efficient.
You could do that, yeah, for sure.
And there are networks we're gonna see
in the YOLO is an example of a network
where in the later versions of YOLO,
it does that automatically.
It can take any resolution
and it just samples it accordingly.
Okay, last activation is gonna be sigmoid.
We wanted the output to be between zero and one
and the architecture, most likely a shallow network.
We don't need too much capacity
unless the task is highly complex
and a convolution should do the work really well.
You don't know what a convolution is yet.
You're gonna know in a few weeks
but those are known to be good
for sequences and for images.
And finally, the loss function.
What loss function would you use?
Oh, which one?
Sigmoid, no, sigmoid is the activation.
What's the loss function?
Logistic loss, yeah.
Logistic loss, also called binary cross-entropy loss,
which is the one you've seen in the videos this week.
You know, yeah, yeah.
So repeating the question,
how much the amount of hardware
and the quality of the hardware you have
at your disposal influences those decisions,
the answer is a lot.
But in fact, I'm assuming you're training it
on your laptop right now, which will work
but you need to make those trade-offs
and I think that's why those skills matter.
Now, if the task is more complicated,
you look at the hardware you have available,
you'll make a quick back of the envelope calculation.
The calculation is really about
how fast our iteration cycles can be.
It's not about necessarily the performance
of the model in the end.
You wanna be able to iterate super quickly
and if your model takes one year to train,
you're not gonna be able to iterate.
You know, you need to reduce it somehow.
So there are situations that were going from like 65.
Yeah, yeah, for sure.
Yeah.
What do you mean?
The-
Like every single-
So the 64 by 64 by three is like literally
you look at a picture and you look at one pixel.
These have three values that describe the color, right?
And then you just flatten it
and then those numbers are given
to the input layer of your neural network.
The input layer of the picture.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's move on just for the sake of time.
This was just the easy warmup.
The two things I just want you to remember
from that project is we're gonna build
a lot of proxy projects and it's important
to remember them for your own project.
So you remember, oh, I remember this experiment
we did on humans or I remember how many images
we needed for that project
and then that can help you make decisions faster.
And then the other thing that is worth highlighting
is the human experiments.
We're gonna do a lot of human experiments
starting with the next example
and those are usually helpful to make quick decisions
in your project when you're in the industry.
So second project, trigger word detection.
Let me give some context on this.
The general problem, okay.
You're familiar with like Alexa and all these,
let's say Siri and things like that
that you might have in your kitchen listening to you.
Everybody knows.
So the way these network typically work,
these models is it's not a single model.
It's a cascade of models
for energy and efficiency purposes.
So for example, if you have a virtual assistant
in your kitchen, the first model is activity detection.
It just detects if there is any volume
because you don't wanna listen
with the heavy model at all time.
It just uses a lot of energy, right?
You want a very lightweight model
that understands when volume is playing.
And so let's say this network detects volume.
It calls another network that is focused
on the activation word, the trigger word.
Alexa, hey Siri, okay Google.
That's usually the second layer.
And that one is only listening for a specific keyword.
If the keyword comes in,
it would typically call a better model
that's slightly slower,
that might be heavier and more energy consumption.
And that might understand what you're trying to do.
And then I'm not gonna go into the details,
but you have architectures that get very complicated.
Back in the day, some of these companies
were doing one model to set up a timer,
one model to buy something online.
One model was very complicated.
Today it's slightly simpler and more end to end,
but I just want you to know the cascade
of models that are being called
because this case study is about the second model,
is about the trigger word.
So here's my problem for you.
Given a 10 second audio speech detects the word activate.
How would you build that off the shelf like that?
Starting from zero.
What data would you collect?
Yep.
Okay.
Like a Fourier transform or?
Okay, what you described is a Fourier transform
or like plus the pre-processing.
You're right.
So you're saying audio is a bunch of frequencies
with values and we wanna first pre-process that
then to give it to an algorithm
and the length of the sequence matters as well.
Because if you wanna detect the word activate,
you know that the length needs to be,
there's a minimum length.
You can't say activate in less than 10 milliseconds, right?
So the length matters as well.
Okay, that's good insight.
What else?
What data?
How would you collect that data?
Yes.
Microphone, like with your phone.
Okay, like you would go around campus and record people.
How would you, what would you ask them to say?
Okay, you would ask, you would record a bunch
of people saying the word activate.
You would ask them anything else?
Other words?
Yeah.
Say a sentence, yeah?
It turns out you have website that are random generators
and you just say, say this and say this
and you record everything.
Yeah.
Say the word deactivate.
Ah, good one.
So you're saying you wanna find negative words
that are close to the positive word.
Just to make sure that the model learns that.
That's a great one, yeah.
Actually, it turns out activate
is a really bad word to choose.
The reason Alexa and actually there was a lot
of discussions at Amazon back in the days
around what would the word be
and turns out it's very important what you choose
because you wanna choose a word
that is not used in common language.
Otherwise, your assistant is always turning on, right?
And Alexa is not ideal either.
It's not bad, but it's not ideal either.
Okay, so let me just narrow down the problem.
Let's say we've gone around campus
and we've collected a bunch of 10-second audio clips.
Okay?
Do we need to think about the distribution of the data?
Like why does it matter?
Like why campus only might be limited, let's say.
Yeah.
Okay, accents.
Turns out the first version of this model
that I built with Andrew,
my German friends could not make it work.
None of my German friends would make it work
and we had to collect more data from,
and I had two German roommates at the time,
so we had to collect more data from them
because there's just a certain way
that people would say words.
Okay, good insight.
What else other than accents?
Yes.
Good point.
Average age on campus is probably younger
than if you actually cross campus and go to Palo Alto.
And in fact, the frequencies are gonna be different
that younger people use.
That's correct.
Yeah.
How fast some people speak fast.
Some people, and it has to do
with the language of origin.
Some people just speak faster.
Correct?
And look at this.
Like when you hear someone who speaks fast
versus someone who speaks slow,
it doesn't make a big difference to you as a human.
But if you actually just had access
to the numbers and the frequencies,
it would look completely different.
So the model actually struggles a lot with that problem.
No.
Yeah, for sure.
Ratio of male to female.
Anything that would modify the frequencies.
And on average, yes, there's different frequencies
or distribution male to female, yeah.
Background noise, very important.
Turns out on Stanford campus, you don't hear the metro.
So it's very likely that your algorithm
will not work for people in New York
that are taking the subway all the time
because of the background noise behind it, yeah.
Okay, I think we get a sense of like,
again, the complexity of the task ahead of us.
Let's say the input is a 10-second audio clip
I'm gonna call X.
And this audio clip has a few things
that are special to it.
So one of the things is negative words,
which are in purple.
Positive words, which are in green,
and then the background is in orange.
Okay, so this is, for example, someone saying,
hi, activate yourself.
Whatever, you see what I mean?
Activate is the positive word.
What's the resolution we'd want?
Okay, I'm not gonna ask you this question
because we don't have speech expert.
A speech expert would know it.
What you can do though, without being a speech expert,
is to go on GitHub and find another speech project
and you actually search for the hyperparameters
they're using.
And if you're using human audio,
you'll find that the same numbers
will work for your project.
Okay?
So you do that little search
and you'll find that there is just a certain
sample rate that works well with human voice.
What's the output?
Zero or one.
Okay, let's try something.
So let's say the output is zero or one.
Zero meaning there is no positive word.
The word activate is not there.
One meaning there is a positive word
in that 10 second audio clip.
So we're gonna do a little human experiment.
I've selected three,
let me turn the volume on.
I've selected three audio samples
of around 10 seconds, okay?
I'm not gonna tell you what the language is, okay?
Because the model doesn't know language.
So you're acting like the model.
That's the experiment.
I'm just telling you that the first
and the third sample have the word
that we're looking for.
And I'm not telling you what the word is,
again, because the model doesn't know
what the word is at the beginning of training, okay?
So now up to you to guess what the word is.
And I hope one of you will save us
and find the word.
Okay, let's try.
Too loud.
Second sample.
Wait, let me see if I can put the microphone here.
Anybody has it, or no?
No, no way, impossible.
Third one.
Okay, who has the word?
Medio?
Okay, maybe, that's not it, but maybe.
Yeah, in the back.
You're Italian?
You speak, okay.
Okay.
Italian?
You speak, okay.
Yeah, it's funny.
Nobody finds it usually in the first try,
but you did find it, yeah.
That's correct.
Okay, let's try again and do it
with a different labeling scheme this time, okay?
Let's try again.
I'm gonna play it again,
but the labeling scheme has changed, okay?
It's the first one.
Third one.
Okay.
What's the word?
Someone who's not Italian speaker?
I'm not sure people heard,
so I wanna try someone else.
Yeah, you've heard it?
Something like PromoDigio.
Okay, not for PromoDigio, it's Pomerigio,
but you're close, you know?
Was it easier the second time or the first time?
Way more, way easier.
So, if it's easier for you,
it's easier for the model, basically.
And so, what is the question I'm posing here is,
we could go with the first labeling scheme,
which is easier for us to label, frankly, right?
You don't need to indicate the location of the word,
but how much more data do you think we need
in order for the model to figure it out?
It's probably 1,000x data, right?
And so, the question is,
is the second labeling scheme 1,000 times harder
for us to label than the first one?
And the answer is no.
So, the answer is very clear.
You would rather have the second labeling scheme,
and your model is gonna learn way faster
than in the first case.
So, that's the type of human experiment you can do.
Now, we're gonna use that labeling scheme.
Yeah, question.
Yeah, we'll talk about it.
Question, is it manual labeling or not?
Yes, right now it's manual,
but I'll explain some tricks we can use, yeah.
Yeah, how do you pick the trade-off
between the different labeling strategies and not?
In fact, today, you could have
a pre-training and a post-training
that have different labeling schemes.
The question is, for pre-training,
you want the model to get really good,
and you wanna avoid a cold start problem.
The problem of the cold start is,
with the first labeling scheme,
maybe even with 1,000 data points
that you collect and label manually,
it's not even gonna understand anything.
So, the second labeling scheme can be a great way
to work around the cold starts.
You might need less data,
but it will start understanding what you mean,
and then the rest of the data
might be labeled differently, essentially.
Okay, let me talk a little bit about the labeling scheme.
We're actually gonna use
a slightly different labeling scheme,
and the reason is, the first,
the one with one, one, and only zeros,
the risk is, you can actually have a model
that performs 99.9% accurate,
that is all zeros, just predict zero all the time.
It's very accurate,
but the thing is, there's just one one to find,
and it's very hard to find it,
and so the network is gonna lean toward zeros,
meaning the data is, the labels are so skewed towards zero
that it's gonna be hard to find any signal in it,
and so the trick that deep learning researchers use
generally is, can we actually do a little more balance
between the positive and the negative labels?
Just a pure engineering hack, not much science behind it.
The last activation, we're gonna use a sigmoid,
but because it's a sequential problem,
we're gonna use sigmoid in sequence.
At every time step, there's gonna be a sigmoid activation.
And then the architecture,
we're gonna learn it later in the class,
you don't need to worry,
this would be likely an R and N.
You'll learn later in the class what that means.
And then the loss function,
can someone guess what loss function we would be using?
Yes?
Binary cross-entropy.
Yeah, binary cross-entropy,
but we're gonna use it sequentially,
meaning at every step,
we're gonna compute that with the sigmoid output, yes?
Correct, you take your input, 10-second inputs,
you look at where the positive word activate is,
and you put ones in there when it plays.
And you force the model to predict,
hey, activate has been played.
There's a lot of nuances you're seeing
because you actually are gonna build this project
with like, do we want the ones to start
exactly when the words start?
Do we wanna have a delay?
There's a lot of technical questions around that.
Yeah, you have a question?
What I mean by steps is audio is a sequence data.
And so it's time step by time step.
And so what I mean is that at every time step,
whatever your sample rate is,
you're gonna have a prediction at every step.
Okay.
So what is critical to the success of this project
is really the labeling strategy.
Here is how we did it.
And you just have to know it or not know it.
It actually takes a long time
to figure something like that out.
And so thankfully, when I was a grad student,
one of my senior PhDs helped me with these methods
and he was able to guide me and save me probably month
because I would not have figured out myself this probably.
So here's what we did.
We took three databases.
We created three databases.
One that would have positive words.
So as you were saying earlier,
we record people for the word activate.
One that would have negative words,
other words, including deactivate,
but also kitchen and lion and dog and whatever.
And then we have background noise.
Turns out background noise in audio data is almost free.
There's just a ton of background noise online.
You can go on many platforms online, video platforms.
You can just take the audio.
It will be background noise.
So background noise is free.
You don't need to go and collect it, most likely.
The other two are harder.
Yeah, question.
Yeah.
So I'll tell you how we do it in a second.
But yes, we recorded everything manually.
What we did is we went online.
We scraped free license data.
Actually, it's a skill to know the licensing models.
You're gonna learn that
in the project mentorship with the TAs.
What licensing allows you to do what with data.
It's good to know forever.
You learn it once and then you know,
what is CC BY, what is CC BY NA,
what is the MIT license,
what is the Apache license, et cetera.
And so we take 10-second audio clips.
We clip the background noise.
And we went around campus
and we literally recorded people saying activate
and other words, and we cut it when they said it.
So the word was contained exactly
to the amount that it was needed.
Then we created a Python script
that randomly inserts words, randomly.
Non-overlapping words.
So for example, this would be created synthetically.
I would have 10-second of background noise.
I would insert two negative words
and I would insert one positive word.
Okay.
The trick is that because the Python script did that,
the Python script knows where activate was put.
So it can label automatically.
And so it turns out that we went around campus.
We used an app even to get help.
So we hired a couple of people to come with us.
Each brought their phone and we went all around campus
recording people to say activate and other words.
And we created those data sets.
Within three hours, we had millions of data points.
Because think about it.
Let's say you have a thousand activates across campus,
10,000 other words, infinite background noise.
Imagine how much data you can create with that.
When you actually write the Python script,
you can also add some data augmentation.
You can reduce some frequencies.
You can augment some frequencies.
You can accelerate it.
You can decelerate it.
So you can actually create a pretty meaningful data sets
for this problem in three hours.
Now I'm talking about training sets
because you don't want to use that data for test sets.
For test sets, you want data to be as real as possible.
You're familiar with the concept
of training test set, right?
So for the test set, we had to manually label data
but it was a much smaller set than the training sets.
Right?
So it's much more convenient.
The second important part was architecture search.
I'm not going to talk about it too much here
but there are architectures that just work better
for these types of problems.
And this is an example of an architecture
on the right that works way better.
And my learning from that project
was just go to the expert and ask them what they've tried
and try to learn from their mistakes.
And in fact, I remember Oni Hanun
which was in the first level
at the Gates Computer Science building.
And he knew that this architecture was going to fail
and he knew why because he's done so many speech projects
and he just knows what works and what doesn't work.
So that's why your TAs are here for
actually in your project.
So you should give them a call and say,
hey, is what I'm doing good or give me a pointer
for what I might spend my next week doing.
Okay, so learnings from this section, this case study,
data collection strategy is extremely important
including the data labeling strategy,
using human experiments matters as well
and then referring to expert advice.
That's the type of thing you wanna do in a project.
Okay, do you understand conceptually
how such project is built now at a high level?
Okay, good.
Yeah, question.
So how often do you need
to do an architecture search nowadays?
Less often than before.
But this class is all about understanding
what's going on under the hood.
So we're gonna walk you through that.
In practice, it depends on your problem.
Like I'll give you, in the industry,
you might be building a company
that requires the model to be running on the browser
and so you have additional constraints
that push you to create your own architecture,
collect your own data,
fine tune the model the way you want.
For many startups out there and companies out there,
you're gonna start from a foundation model.
You're gonna start from a foundation model
and then you might actually quantize it
or prune it or modify it to meet your needs
in terms of latency, in terms of memory,
in terms of hardware capacity
and knowing what's going on like we did
is important in those cases.
Yeah.
Okay, super.
So we're one hour in.
We are about halfway through the class,
a little bit ahead
and I have a few more case studies to cover with you.
Okay.
By the end, we'll have a full set of proxy projects
to work with, okay?
So this one is cool.
It's face verification.
A school wants to use face verification
to validate student IDs in facilities
like dining halls, gym and pool.
So let me explain what it is.
It's like you arrive at the Ariaga gym
and instead of just, you know,
normally you would swipe your student ID, right?
And your picture will show up on the screen
and there's someone sitting there.
It's gonna compare the picture they're seeing
on the screen to the picture they're seeing
with their eyes.
And if it's the same, they're gonna say,
you can go ahead, right?
It's slightly different.
Here, you're gonna be verified by a camera.
So there's actually a camera ahead
and you're walking in and you're swiping your card
and we're gonna compare the picture in the database
to the picture that is being taken by the camera
to make sure that it's the same person, okay?
How do you get started?
Okay, so everybody who got admitted uploaded pictures,
at least one.
So we have that already in the database, correct?
Yeah, what else?
You're saying the camera matters?
Yeah, for sure.
The camera matters.
In fact, we talked about resolution.
Do you think the resolution is lower
or higher than the day and night project?
Probably higher.
In fact, it's gonna be higher.
And again, I would go back to literally doing
a human experiment and showing pictures of twins
and asking people if they can differentiate the twins
and you'll see that the resolution matters actually.
Okay, yeah, you wanted to add something?
Okay, also data from outside the university.
Which features?
Understand the person's human feature
but they're already in the picture, right?
So the picture would have the feature
or you would add anything on top of that.
So typically, you would not actually wanna
get to the feature level.
You would just wanna say,
we need to make sure it's in the data.
If it's in the data, the neural network will learn it.
Absolutely.
Same person multiple times because the angle matters,
the time matters, et cetera.
Yeah.
Okay, same thing.
Okay.
Okay, so you're saying we might do some pre-processing
to crop all the images so that it's centered
or at least that the image that we're trained
the model with looks like the image
that the camera is gonna take
because the model will run on the camera.
Okay, all these are good.
So let's say our data set is picture of every student
labeled with their name.
So this is one of my friends Bertrand
and he has his picture,
which is his picture from the student ID.
And then the input is,
okay, he shows up in front of the building.
He's a little bit confused,
but he showed up and a picture was taken.
The resolution, we talked about it.
What we use here is 412, 412 by three.
It's much higher than before.
Okay, as we were expecting
because we need small details.
Even eye color is identifiable, right?
So these things we cannot find without a higher resolution.
In fact, if you actually go through airport security
and you use some of these fast tracks
which take a picture of you,
trust me, the resolution is gonna be even higher
than that, much higher than that
because they're actually getting into the iris
at that level, right?
So what's the output?
The output is zero or one.
Yeah, it's Bertrand or it's not Bertrand.
Okay, we're good so far.
The architecture, let me actually ask you,
how would you do this comparison without neural networks?
Let's say a very basic way.
If you had to start with the first method.
Yeah. So you would feature engineer,
you would say like, for example,
you would define 10 features that are good for identifying people,
and you would have a filter for each of them,
and you would run it on the picture and say,
yes, do we have this feature or not, essentially?
Okay, yeah, it's a good one.
Even more basic than that would be pixel comparison.
You just compare the two pixels.
What's the problem with doing a pixel comparison?
So the idea is I take the two pictures,
I compare them,
and if they're close enough in pixel-wise comparison,
then it's the same person.
If they're far, it's not the same person.
What can go wrong?
Difference in what?
Lighting.
Lighting, yeah. Actually, what's interesting with the lighting is if you look here,
so in this one,
you take the top left pixel right here, okay?
It's bright. You take the top left pixel on this one,
it's dark or at least dark green.
The difference between these two pixels is massive.
It's close to 255,
yet the pixel doesn't even matter.
So why would you use that?
It would penalize the comparison without actually mattering at all.
So that's a good point, yeah.
Yeah, absolutely. Background difference.
Translation invariance, like imagine the same picture,
but the person is like three pixels to the right.
The comparison will be completely different because it's
a pixel comparison rather than a semantically meaningful comparison, okay?
What are other things that can go wrong?
Distance from the camera.
Again, you know,
rotation invariance, translation invariance, scale invariance,
all of these matter.
What are other things that are not geometric modifications?
Yeah? Wearing glasses or hats.
Wearing glasses or hats. What else?
Hairstyle, yeah. The beard, you know.
And in fact, you look here,
he has much more beard than on the picture.
And he was much younger, by the way, on the first picture.
And oftentimes, we look,
we're younger on our student IDs than we actually are in person,
and that may make a difference.
Okay. So, these issues we all talked about.
I think people get it. Good.
So, our solution is to use the concept of encoding.
You remember what we talked about earlier with the face example.
It turns out a network that has been trained to understand faces
should have meaningful information in
those layers that you can use as comparison,
that is more meaningful than a pixel comparison.
So, this is how it goes.
We have Bertrand picture from the student ID.
We run it through a deep neural network and we get a vector.
What is this vector? It's a vector that we grab in the middle of the network somewhere.
Remember what I said, if the vector is taken earlier in the network,
we're going to get lower level features.
If you go deeper,
it's going to get more facial features.
So, you probably go slightly deeper.
You go much deeper actually for this example.
And then same thing, you run the exact same network on the picture from the camera.
And normally, if the network was trained well,
those two vectors should be close to each other.
This tends to be 0.4.
You set the threshold.
You might do a little study to see what's the right threshold.
And of course, this threshold is going to determine
the number of true positives that you're going to get versus
false positives versus false negatives, you know.
The higher the threshold, the more likely you make a mistake,
the more relaxed you are, right?
So, here, let's say I set a threshold of 0.5.
Hey, I'm confident enough that this is Bertrand.
And again, airport security might have a much higher lower threshold
than the dining hall at Stanford, obviously, you know.
Okay. So, this is the general idea behind what we want to do.
But I still haven't talked to you about how the network is trained.
The network right now is not trained.
We haven't learned how to train it.
Yeah, question.
What's the network? We'll learn it actually.
We're going to see it together. Yeah, I'll describe it.
But I don't want to get into the architectural nitty-gritty.
I want to focus on the general training scheme that we're going to use.
And then you're actually going to build that at some point in the quarter.
Yeah. Other question?
Yeah. What are the hidden features in the 128-dimensional vector?
We don't know. That's the point of deep learning,
is you have to create a loss function that
will modify your parameters in a way that forces it to learn features.
But I can tell you that a dimension number three is for eyes,
and dimension number six is for ears.
I can make a study.
We'll study it later this quarter and tell you that
this neuron is actually good at detecting certain types of features.
But right now I can't tell you, unless I do that study now.
Okay. So, question for you.
What- how would you build a training and
a loss function to make that possible to train that network?
You have ideas. It's not an easy question.
Try. Where to start?
Yes. So, mean squared error between what?
You're right, actually. Two vectors,
mean squared error because it's a, you know, yeah.
But- so, are you saying we would take pairs of pictures,
we will run it through the network,
we will then take the two vectors that we get,
and do- apply the loss function,
some distance, L1 distance,
L2 distance, and then trace it back and say,
these were the same people,
you should have been closer.
That's what you mean? Yeah, it's a good idea.
Yeah. Someone else wanted to say something?
Yeah. That's another one,
cosine similarity that could also be our loss function.
Okay. Like what? Great idea.
Data augmentation. So, you would- you say,
I can take the picture of Bertrand and probably mirror it,
flip it, rotate it,
crop it, and I would use more data that way?
Yeah, absolutely. That's- that would help a lot actually.
Okay. So, all of these are good ones.
If I summarize your points though,
because that's really the key to the designing a good loss function,
what we really want is that similar- picture of
the same person end up with similar vectors,
and picture of different people end up with different vectors,
if we rephrase it in plain English.
So, what we'll do is that we'll build a data set of triplets.
The triplets includes a picture that is the anchor,
a picture that is the positive.
The reason it's called positive is because it's the same person as the anchor,
and a picture that is called the negative because it's
a different person than the anchor and by definition,
also a different person than the positive.
One picture of a person?
Great question. If you have one picture of a person,
then you can't do that.
We'll actually see another method that would allow us to do it even with one pi-
one picture of a person.
Yeah. You can rotate it, that's true.
You- you could actually do some data augmentation as he was
mentioning and build a data set starting with one picture.
But this approach will not be the best one.
We'll see another approach right after that would work better.
Yeah. Good question.
Why do we compare a vector rather than the output of the model, right?
So, what's the output of the model?
We actually haven't talked about the architecture,
but I'm assuming you're saying it's a binary number in between zero and one.
Because it's a single dimension,
it cannot hold meaningful information.
So, you probably want to have a vector that is big enough where you believe it has
enough flexibility to hold information that can
allow us to verify if the same person is on the picture.
No, essentially. Okay. I'm going to move on and if there's- so,
what we want is to minimize the encoding distance
between the anchor and the positive and we want to
maximize the encoding distance between the anchor and the negative.
So, question for you.
What I'm going to ask you is to take 10-15 seconds,
look at the slide and you're going to start voting for A, B, or C.
By the way, Anc is encoding.
It's just how I call the vector that we get out of the network.
A is the anchor, N is the negative,
and P is the positive.
So, A is the anchor picture,
N is the negative picture,
which is different from the anchor, the different person,
and P is the positive picture,
which is the same as the anchor.
An Anc of A is when you run A through the network,
you get the vector Anc of A. Okay.
Let's look at the results.
A. 47 for A,
23 for B, 3 for C. So,
someone who said good job first, that is correct.
Someone who selected A wants to tell us why.
Yeah. Correct. Correct. Great.
So, actually the key word here is minimize.
If I had said maximize,
the answer indeed as you say would have been different because here we're
looking at minimizing the distance between the anchor and the positive,
and in fact minimizing this or maximizing the opposite of it.
That's why the answer is A. Okay. Good stuff.
Let's keep going. So,
going back to the initial setup,
we had a cat and we were predicting a binary number.
Here instead we have three pictures going through the network in parallel.
So, you can imagine it's batch processing.
It's like the three are going in the same network at the same time,
and then you're getting three vectors.
You're computing the loss function.
Okay. You're doing this loss function we talked about.
I'm not going to talk here about the alpha number,
but you're going to learn when you build it why the alpha number matters.
Hint is maybe zero would have been
a correct answer if you didn't have the alpha number.
So, it would have created instability in the model.
But you do that many, many times.
You push the parameters to the right or the left,
and because of the way you created your loss function and your data labeling,
the way you structured your data and the loss function,
essentially the model is going to learn by itself to create
similar encoding for pictures that are of the same person and
separate encodings for pictures that are not from the same person.
You didn't need to do feature engineering.
You didn't need to talk about eyes and ears and
whatever because it will figure it out.
You know that you created the learning environment to allow that to happen.
So, congratulations, you designed your first loss function,
and we're going to design many more in this course.
This, by the way, is from FaceNet.
It's a paper from 2015 from Chautetal,
and you've seen in the slides I used,
I always put the reference to
the papers in case you want to go back and study the actual paper.
Many students do it for their projects.
This is a great one,
great paper to look, a lot of citations as well.
Let me make it slightly more complicated.
We learned face verification,
now we want to do face identification.
How is that different?
Identification is a school
wants to recognize students in facilities.
So, imagine face verification is you swiped
your card and then that picture was compared to the picture of the camera.
That's verification, the two, are they the same or not?
Identification is you have this picture in the database somewhere,
the person enters, immediately you can identify them.
So, the difference for those of you who fly in the US is,
when you go through global entry,
many people don't even need to put their passport or anything.
They just watch, look at the camera and they move on.
That's identification.
But actually, when you're in Europe, for example,
you put your passport in,
then you walk in,
then it takes a picture, that's verification.
You see the difference or no?
The negative or how do you create those triplets essentially?
No, in real time, that's a great question I didn't talk about.
So, at train time,
you have databases and you create the triplets automatically.
You pick pictures from the same person or you use
data augmentation and you add a random picture from someone else.
You create millions of triplets like that or
billions of triplets. At test time,
you only take the picture from the camera,
run it, you don't use a negative.
You just take the picture from the camera,
you run it through the network,
the person swipes, you take the picture from the swipe,
run it through the network,
you do the comparison, you let them in or not.
So, there's no more negative at test time in practice.
It's just a trick to train the model.
So, how would you do face identification
using what we learned for face verification?
Is there any small tweak you can make that would
make this network work for identification?
Yes. Correct. Correct.
What is it called in machine learning?
There's a machine learning algorithm that we
can stack on top of what we just did.
He said you can compare.
So, because we don't have two pictures anymore,
we just have one from the camera.
You just compare the vector of the- you run this by the network,
you get the vector and then you compare it to the database.
No. Good try.
You have a database of all the student pictures,
you run everything through the network.
Instead of storing the image,
you store the vectors.
Then someone shows up and you're looking in the database,
is there any vector that is super close to this one?
That's identification. What is
this algorithm called in machine learning?
It's a pretty simple algorithm.
No. Okay. I'm going to make it easier.
What if instead of having one picture
of a student in the database,
you had three of each students,
you have three vectors for each person,
and then you're trying to find
the nearest vectors in the database
from the one that the camera takes.
I used the keyword.
No. Yeah. K-nearest neighbors.
That's a K-nearest neighbor algorithm.
It's essentially- you want to explain what you meant?
Why is it K-nearest neighbor?
Yeah. It's K-nearest neighbor for
high-dimensional vectors. So here is
a simple example of K-nearest neighbor for two dimensions.
In practice, it's 128 dimensions,
so I can't put it on the slide, of course.
But let's say in green,
you have the query point.
The query point is the camera picture.
Okay? Then you run a nearest neighbor algorithm and you say,
are there three vectors in the database
that are close to this vector?
You can add additional checks.
Are these three vectors from the same person?
If they are, then it's very likely the person is correct
because you just could prove that
the three closest vectors in the database are
from the same person three times.
So it's higher likelihood.
You could even do it for
10 nearest neighbor if you want to be really secure.
Let's say you go to the airport every time,
and every time they take a picture of you,
and now they can do a 10 nearest neighbor on that search.
Does that make sense? Now it's slightly more complicated.
You want to do face clustering.
So you know in your phone sometimes it says,
it put automatically all the pictures from your mom in
one folder and from your dad in another folder, right?
How does it do it?
How could you make a tweak to again what we created or encoding network?
How can you use that to create that?
K-means, yeah, exactly.
K-means algorithm, which is
an unsupervised learning algorithm clustering.
So you have a bunch of pictures,
you have vectorized all of them with the network you trained,
and normally the vectors that are from the same person
should be clustered around the same place,
and that's very simply how big companies do it on your phone.
Yes. Yeah. So if the person is not in the database,
then you shouldn't find any vector
that is close to the vector you're taking picture of.
The closest vector might be above
your threshold in terms of distance,
and you wouldn't let that person in. Yeah, for sure.
Yeah, they make you sign up there.
So it's interesting because companies know that they need to build
these net- these algorithms and then some like the admission process,
the sign-up process might include certain data points,
and now you're starting to understand how it's used in the background, right?
Okay. Let's move on.
Yeah, one question. Oh, good question.
So are you comparing each new picture?
So I take a picture of my mom with my phone.
What's going to happen?
This picture is going to likely,
if you're doing clustering,
is going to be compared to the centroid of my mom.
So the phone keeps probably a centroid of my mom,
and if it's close enough to the centroid over another centroid,
it's going to probably put it in that folder, essentially.
No. Yeah, one more question and then we move on.
Yeah, there is- okay.
How many- how do you figure out how many centroids you want?
There is an algorithm.
I- you'll study it in CS229,
not in CS230, but you know.
Okay. Okay.
What we learned here is what an encoder network is.
We learned about positive,
anchor, negative, for the triplet loss.
The loss I showed you is called the triplet loss,
because of the triplets.
And then we learned the different variations
of phase verification, identification, and clustering.
Now, we're going to get to an interesting section,
which is brand new around self-supervised learning.
So note that everything we did so far,
the day and night classification,
the trigger word detection,
and the triplet loss were supervised learning.
We had labels, essentially.
Day and night is very classic supervised learning.
You label data with zero and one.
Same for trigger word detection,
phase verification, you can- can- can debate,
it can be different.
But anyway, we- we focused on supervised learning.
Now, we're going to talk about self-supervised learning.
And my question for you is the following.
Labeling is expensive. We know that.
So how would you redo what we did with
a different approach that does not require labels?
Meaning, you remember even in phase verification,
we sort of had the name of the students in
the database with their face
and we might have multiple pictures of them.
Let's say you don't even have that.
You just have faces in the wild, unlabeled.
How would you do things differently?
Any idea? Yeah. Okay.
Let the neural network find
the pictures that are close to each other.
But how would you train that network?
Like, you're starting with a network
that doesn't do anything and you give it an image,
it gives you a random vector at first.
So how would you train it?
Yeah. Do some clustering offline.
But again, my question is the clustering algorithm,
how is it trained? How do you cluster?
If you don't have any encoder network.
Because the clustering came after
we trained the encoder network.
The clustering only worked because we had
a good encoder network.
But you don't know if it's the same person.
That's what I'm saying is that-
Vectors would be similar.
No, because that's the network you're training.
The vectors are not similar because
that's the network we want to train.
Right now, I gave you a network.
It's completely random.
You give it my picture on Saturday and on Sunday,
the vectors are completely off.
So how do you start? Yeah.
Okay. Tell me more.
Okay. Yeah, you're ahead.
But we'll study that in two weeks, actually.
So we'll do autoencoders two weeks from now in class.
Anyone else has an idea?
Yeah. Okay.
It's actually similar to what he was saying
to reconstruct the original image.
Yeah, that's what we learned.
There's a lot of methods.
Diffusion models work like that, autoencoders.
We learn about that in two weeks
when we focus on generative AI, generative modeling.
Here, I want to present also a generative method,
but it's really interesting because it will be
your foray into self-supervised learning.
Here is the idea.
If we have pictures in the wild,
going with the methods you had mentioned around data augmentation,
you can actually force the network to learn from the data itself.
So let me give you an example.
I take, you look at the picture of this dog,
and you rotate it by 90 degrees.
It's still the same dog.
A human would say it's the same dog.
What are we using in our brain?
We're using the ability to understand rotation invariance
and to understand the semantics of the dog.
And so technically, if you gave those two images to the network,
you could create a loss function that compares those two pairs
and has to have vectors that are close to each other.
Does that make sense?
Other thing you could do, you can do a patch.
You can literally take an image of a face
and put the patch on half of the image.
And then you do the same thing on the other image.
You put the other patch, the other half,
and now you tell the network these two should have the same vector,
pretty much.
So you use your data augmentation scheme
on massive datasets online
to force the network to learn from the data itself.
Okay?
No need to forge triplets per se.
You just take a picture.
You make a variance of it with noise, with rotation,
with cropping, with translation, with whatever you want.
And then you put these two in the dataset
and you say these are two the same person.
It should have the same vector.
Does that make sense?
That's why it's called self-supervised learning
because you don't have labels.
You just create a learning environment
that makes the network learn
from the patterns of the data directly itself.
Okay, so this is an example called Sinclair.
Again, the paper is right there.
And this shifts from supervised triplets,
FaceNet, which was a paper from 2015,
to self-supervised pairs.
That is why modern models are trained
on billions of unlabeled images.
Okay?
That's how we create.
It's much simpler when you think about it.
You can literally write a script and scrape
and it will label, auto-label the images
and put them in pairs, do variations.
And then you'll end up
with a very powerful pre-trained model.
Much simpler than people think.
It's not that hard, you know, at the end of the day.
Most of the complexities are gonna come from compute.
Right?
Okay, so this method is called contrastive learning.
Okay?
We're gonna talk about it a little more in two weeks.
Self-supervision is not only an image thing.
It's also used in other modalities.
For example, in text, the principle is the same.
You predict what belongs together
and you push away what doesn't.
That's for images.
And here, what the core of GPT,
some of you probably have heard of that,
is a method called next token prediction.
We're gonna learn later about tokens in the class,
but today, forget about tokens, just think the words.
We're trying to look at a sentence
and predict the next word.
Why is this self-supervised learning?
Because you don't label data.
You just literally grab data from online
and you create a scheme that forces the model
to learn from the patterns of the data
using self-supervised learning,
but the self comes from the fact
that you didn't label it manually yourself.
So let's do a few examples.
And the reason I wanna do the examples
is because we wanna talk about emergent behaviors
that stem from the tasks we defined.
So give me the word you're thinking of.
I poured myself a cup of,
some people said tea, coffee.
Anybody said anything else?
Water, a cup of water.
Healthy people said water, okay.
Yeah, so what's the emergent behavior
that you can expect the model is gonna learn
based on just that example?
Yeah, good point, because you know that
whatever is here first fits in a cup.
So it understands that.
The second reason is poured.
So it's a liquid.
So just this sentence without even labeling
is going to generate emergent behaviors
that we've never trained the model for.
That's what's interesting about modern AI, if you will.
You don't need to define the tasks.
Frankly, the same way, think about face verification.
Back in the days, we used to do what I showed you
where we would create triplets
and we would be very specific
about this is for face verification.
You could actually scrape all the images online
and do the contrastive learning that I showed you next.
And it will still be good at detecting faces
without you having even defined that task
in the first place,
just by doing the contrastive prediction.
Second, okay, first example also,
again, I was trying to predict,
but people usually say different things.
I think the majority of people think coffee.
It's very cultural.
You go in another country, it's gonna be tea, for sure.
And that forces the model to really think
about everyday co-occurrence pattern,
like them being liquid, being of a certain size,
occurring together.
So for example, there's probably a lot of sentences online
that says pouring a cup of tea,
and there's a lot saying pouring a cup of coffee.
Because of that, the model should understand
that these two things are probably close to each other
because their context is similar.
Second example, the capital of France is?
Nobody?
Huh?
Paris, okay.
What's the emergent behavior
you can expect the model to learn?
Yeah, learn about facts, exactly.
So this is really predicting the next token forces the model
to encode real world facts,
such as Paris being the capital of France.
Oops, sorry.
What about the third example?
She unlocked her phone using her?
Body parts.
I don't know what your phone,
type of phone you have, but.
Wait, what would you say?
Face.
Password.
Fingerprint.
Yeah, all of them are possible.
So again, the network would learn probably
that password, fingerprint, and face
can be used to unlock stuff.
Yeah, and in fact here, probably fingerprint or face
might nowadays be the more common
because of how the world has evolved,
but back in the days it would be password, for sure.
And so this forces a semantic understanding
that these things are probably all meant
to unlock information.
The next one, the cat chased the dog or mouth or ball.
And again, the model will learn probabilistic reasoning,
meaning because in the data set,
it will find variations of the sentence
with different actually conclusion.
It would say that there's a lot of things
that the cat can chase.
And so that's probabilistic reasoning.
What about the last one?
If it's raining, I should bring on
umbrella, what's the emergent behavior?
It's reasoning and inference,
is the model will learn to connect conditions.
So for example, raining requires you
to be protecting yourself from the rain with an umbrella.
That's reasoning, okay?
So long story short, emergent behaviors
are unexpected capabilities that arise
from simple training objectives at scale
without being explicitly taught or labeled.
Later in this class, we're gonna have a full lecture
on deep reinforcement learning,
where we're gonna talk about emergent behaviors
in robotics or in gaming,
where turns out the agent your training learns
to do certain strategies
that you didn't expect they would do.
AlphaGo is a good example
if you've watched the documentary.
Okay.
Self-supervision is not just about text and images.
We've seen the next token prediction for GPT
and we've also seen contrastive learning for images.
My question here is the following.
What other examples of modalities can you think of?
And tell me the task that you would define.
Audio, so for audio, what would you do?
Audio, how would you do a self-supervision in audio?
Exactly, mask out portion.
So mask out 20 time steps.
And because you know what the data was,
you have a label, you knew what the truth was.
You can do a self-supervision task, it would work great.
The limitation is compute and scale.
What other modalities?
So self-driving is a good example.
It's very multimodal.
There's a lot of different things happening
in self-driving.
We'll talk about it in a future lecture.
What else, what other modalities can you think of?
Videos, what would you do, video?
Take frames out, you can take some frames out.
Same principle as audio.
Biology, some people work in healthcare biology here.
Yeah, a couple.
Well, you know about amino acids and protein structure.
You can actually mask portion of the inputs
such as a protein structure or DNA and then complete it.
And it will force the model to understand those patterns.
So great stuff in there.
But the world is very multimodal.
We experience words, images, sounds and actions together.
How can we connect them?
When you think about multimodality,
you wanna connect texts and images, let's say.
What do you need to do those?
You actually need labeled data.
You need image captions.
So for example, you have a bunch of picture online
of the cat is looking at the camera.
So there's a picture and there's a label underneath,
just like on Instagram.
Let's say people put captions, right?
And the reason you can connect those modalities
is because of that data set.
Because you have a lot of that.
Now, this is not typically called supervised learning.
It will be called weekly supervised learning
because you're not actually labeling images with captions.
You are benefiting from naturally occurring pairings
in the world.
There is naturally occurring pairings
of images and texts, okay?
So now what I want you to do
is to find other examples
that are not just images captioned,
but naturally occurring examples of different modalities
that appear in the wild together
that we could use to connect modalities.
The whole point of connecting modalities
is that our vectors now can represent
different modalities close to each other in space.
Okay?
So think about that.
Please continue.
I'm gonna read some of the answers,
but we keep going.
Okay, so stock price sequence is a single modality.
You would look at stock price
and you can mask and then predict.
But I think maybe what you mean
is you would put additional data points in there as well.
Let me see if I have something.
Audio paired with video.
Audio and video is a great one.
Audio and video is naturally paired.
You take a YouTube video.
It has the audio and the video.
And so when a dog is barking,
you have the audio of the dog barking
and the video of the dog barking.
And so you can create a pairing
between those two modalities.
Transcription.
So a lot of movies have subtitles.
And so by definition, a video stream
or stream of images will be naturally connected to text,
which would also be naturally connected to audio.
Music and song title.
Again, that's a great one.
Audio and text are connected.
Genotype and phenotype.
Good one as well.
Medical imaging with ultrasound.
That's a great one.
Naturally occurring.
You usually, if you go to an ultrasound,
you'll have the different types of images
that occur together naturally.
Game footage and keyboard action.
Again, another great one.
So, you know, price scenario code.
Good one.
Yeah, great examples.
Facial expression.
So TLDR is we have ways to connect modalities.
Oftentimes, some modalities
are gonna connect very naturally.
Most things connect to text.
So that's what you wanna use
as your shared space typically.
But here, it is an example of a paper called ImageBind.
And the interesting thing about ImageBind is it says
that most things connect through a single modality.
So for example, thermal data connects to imaging.
Imaging connects to text.
So text is gonna connect through images with thermal data.
And what's the consequence of that,
if I may show you a little example,
is that you can, this is a demo from Meta
called ImageBind.
It's a cool one.
You can actually see things occurring together.
So for example, you put a text, drums,
and of course, you can get an audio of a drum.
But you can also see what the closest image
in the vector space is to that concept.
So all the spaces are now bound together.
You can also do audio and image.
So you give it a dog barking and a picture.
What can you expect?
A dog on the beach.
That's the multimodal embedding,
the connecting tissue between those different modalities.
And that's probably one of the biggest innovation
of the last few years, connecting those shared spaces.
Okay, I'm not gonna cover the full paper,
but the core insight is that there are shared spaces.
There are spaces like text and image
that connect to most modalities
that can allow us to connect those modalities together.
Okay, we learned a lot of things here.
Embeddings, self-supervised learning,
contrastive learning, data augmentation,
next token prediction, weekly supervised learning,
and then the shared embedding stays
with the central pivot usually being text.
Okay, that's all for today.
We're not gonna have time to cover the adversarial example,
but we're gonna cover it in two weeks together.
You're gonna have more neural network baggage.